[موسيقى]
كيف يمكن ان نصل الى المعرفه بضغطه زر
قبل 150 عام خرج علينا فيلسوف مثير للجدل
هو كار ماركس واعتقد انه يثير جدل اليوم
قال ان البرجوازيه صبغت العالم كله بلونها
اجزم لو ان ماركس نهض اليوم لقال ان
التقنيه صبغت العالم كله
كلامي سيكون عن التقنيه هذا الوحش الذي
يصعب ترويضه والسيطره عليه كيف نتعامل معه
وفي اي زمن نحن نعيش
هناك شبه اجماع نحن نعيش في الثوره
الثالثه بحسب الفينتوفلر عالم المستقبليات
الامريكي الشهير يرى ان البشريه مرت
بثلاثه ثورات كبرى
الثوره الزراعيه استمرت عشره الاف عام
وكانت ثوره استقرار الانسان على الارض
الانسان عندما وجد الكلا والماء والزراعه
استقر
والثوره الصناعيه قبل 300 عام يسميها
الفلار ثوره السيطره على الارض السؤال
الان ماذا بعد السيطره احتواء الارض
الثوره التقنيه التي نعيش الان في ظلالها
منذ حوالي 40 عام احتواء الارض كيف يتم
هذا الاحتواء
سابقا عند مريضه اتعلم معلومه
هذه المعلومه تاتيني بشكل عمودي من
الاستاذ في المدرسه من الشيخ في الجامع من
الاستاذ بالجامعه من الاب للابن كما يقال
من جيل الاباء للابناء تستمر هذه العمليه
20 عام مع الثوره التقنيه المعلومه تاتي
بلحظه واحده ما يحدث في امريكا واليابان
ياتي الينا في ثانيه اصبحت تعليم افقيا لا
وجود للتعليم العمودي هذا ايضا يظهر لنا
انه الدوري الاستاذ الذي يملك درس على
التلاميذ قد انحسر وتلاشى لان الاستاذ في
اللحظه التي يلقي فيها المعلومه للتلاميذ
هو تلميذ لهم عن طريق الحوار والنقاش
السؤال الان التحدي التقني مع هاي
السوشيال ميديا الرهيبه كيف نتعامل معه
اني بالحقيقه شفت اكو تحدي هائل لاني اعمل
في مجال الكتب انحسار الورق والقراءه وما
كما نعرف هناك كلاسيكيات عظمى الفكر
الانساني من ملحمه الجمهوريه الفلاطون كتب
ديكارت كانت هيجل كانت التحدي كيف تنقل
هذه المعرفه هذه الكتب هذا الورق الى
السوشال ميديا بكلام
مختصر مكثف جدا بدقائق معدوده تتجنب بها
اللغه الاكاديميه العاليه وتكون بطريقه
شعبيه
ولان خوارزميات السوشيال ميديا تخبرنا بان
الزمن يتقاطع مع الانتشار كلما قلت نسبه
كلما زادت الوقت قلت المشاهده يعني
الفيديو ابو العشر دقائق جرب سوي خمس
دقائق سوي دقيقه كل ما يقل الزمن يتوسع
الانتشار اذا احنا امام الزمن يختلف عن
الزمن القديم ونحن نلاحظ انهيار الاعلام
التقليدي قبل فتره قليله عندنا احد
القنوات العريقه في الاذاعه اغلقت ابوابها
لانه ما استطاعت تخاطب الجيل الجديد
واليوم يتحدثون عن زمن البودكاست انه هو
لزمن القادم
الان انت بامكانك ان تسير في الشارع وهذه
اول مره من الفين عام وتؤدي كل اعمالك
وانت بالشارع عن طريق هاي السماعه تضع
الموبايل هذا الموبايل ما يفارقنا 24 ساعه
باليوم يلازمنا اكثر من اهلنا
انت تسير بالشارع تتعلم
وتضارب بالبورصه
وتبيع وتشتري حتى فكره اللابتوب جاءت من
فوق الركبه لان الانسان يؤدي كل اعماله
وهو جالس
اذا كيف استطيع ان انقل هذه المعرفه الى
المجال التقني في غضون اربعين ثانيه حتى
اختصر وفي الادب قيل قديما الملل سلاح
الشيطان الاقوى ساذكر تجربتي باختصار شديد
مع اهم 6 اسماء كيف استطعت ايصالها
للجمهور بفيديوهات لا تتجاوز الدقيقتين
ديكارت انا افكر اذا انا موجود كل النهضه
الان نعيشها بدات من الان من العقلانيه هل
قراتم كتابه مقال على المنهج 1637 هاي
اعوام مهمه ذكر طورت وقتل في السويت كحاله
قال مفكر يخرج عن العصر يقول في السطر
الاول من الكتاب عباره هائله العقل اعدل
الاشياء قسمه بين الناس لا يمكن لامه من
الامم ان تنهض اذا نحت العقل جانبا وسيطرت
عليها الخرافات والاساطير في الكتاب
يرى ديكارت صاحب انا افكر اذا انا موجود
يقول الحقيقه ليست ما يجمع عليه الناس
الحقيقه ما تقبض عليه انت بيدك هذا العقل
الهائل الذي زلزل اوروبا رحل عام 1650 عن
اربعه وخمسين عام فقط اخذ الشعله من بعده
كانت كن جريئا في استخدام عقلك وهو يرى ان
الطفل يخرج من بطن امه باكيا هاي صرخه
الحريه هل تعلمون ان الزلزال الهائل في
اوروبا التنوير خرج في مقال لم يخرج بكتاب
ولا بمدفع ولا بصاروخ يقول ولد يرد في قصه
الحضاره كان الافضل لنابليون من كل الحروب
التي خاضها وارواح مليون انسان قتلها ان
يكتب اربع كتب بس اربع كتب اسمي نوزل عقد
الهائل الذي يجد العالم الان صعوبه في فهم
كتبه كن جريئا في استخدام عقلك مقال في
مجله برلين الشهريه عام 1784 ثالثا فرويد
الوعي واللاوعي كنا نظن سابقا قبل فرويد
ان الوعي هذا يتحكم بافعالنا ف
ذكريات الطفوله
الرغبات المكبوته المواقف المخجله هي التي
تسير الانسان وثمانين بالمئه
شبه الامر مثل جبل الثلج جزء ظاهر فقط فوق
سطح الماء هو الوعي والجزء الاكبر هو
اللاوعي مع روسو هل تعلمون ان الفلسفه
السياسيه خرجت بسطر الاول من العقد
الاجتماعي ولد الانسان حرا والاغلال تحيط
به في كل مكان حتى لا اظلم لا اظلم عربيا
اختم باسميا ابن خلدون وعلي الوردي اللي
اعتبره طبيب المجتمع العراقي ابن خلدون
مؤسس علم الاجتماع وفي خلاف لكن ارجع الى
مقدمته
حصن قلعتك من الداخل يخشاك العدو دائما
القوه تاتي من الداخل مو من الخارج حتى
بالاجسام شفنا بكورونا عندك مناعه انت
اقوى حصل نفسك من الداخل اختم بعدل وردي
اللي حاولت قدر الامكان ايصال افكار عن
الورد يتكلم عن امراض المجتمع العراقي قبل
70 عام وحاضر في كليه الملكه عاليه عام 51
قال نحن مصابون بثلاثه امراض
تناشز الاجتماعي صراع البداوى الحضاره
والازدواجيه الشخصيه ما اريد ان اقول في
نهايه المطاف ما قال جاروتي الذي يعشقه في
كتابه حفار والقبور ليس المستقبل ما سيكون
بل ما سنصنعه هذا العصر وهذه قوانينه الا
ندركهم ندخل خلالها سنصبح سخريه للتاريخ
شكرا لاصغائكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]